i'm chloe gong i'm currently a full-time  author living in new york and before i  graduated college that is something i  could have never imagined saying it was  my passion that i kept under the table i  only thought of it as a hobby then  senior year rolled around and there was  a worldwide pandemic and as i was  nearing graduation it was so hard to get  a job a  real job i just sat there thinking can i  decide to graduate college and just take  a leap of faith and become a full-time  author  and i thought well  why not right i'm gonna make it work  and so now i'm here i have two books out  and i have many many more contracts  lined up and i'm going to make it work  because i decided that i would and at  the end of the day for the creative arts  i think having faith in yourself is the  most important thing